[Music]
hey guys it's Johanna here I can give
you tons of reasons why you should have
more vegetables and you should have your
vegetables every single day but let me
just give you five quick reasons if you
want to have good hair good skin good
nails have your vegetables if you are
looking to lose weight and you want a
low calorie option vegetables they are
extremely low in calories if you want to
suppress your appetite avoid mindless
munching vegetables are extremely high
in fiber and they would keep you
satisfied for a long time if you want to
be healthy feel healthy look young and
feel young have your vegetables they are
known to help with anti aging and if you
want to lift your mood up feel energized
throughout the day vegetables will
provide you with lots of energy because
it helps to stabilize your blood sugar
level what we are going to make today
are three classic Christmas vegetables
which you can make for your Christmas
meals all throughout the year they are
extremely simple to make with minimal
ingredients because we want the
highlight of the dish to be your
vegetables so we want the natural
sweetness and taste from the vegetables
each dish only takes less than 15
minutes to prepare so it's really
convenient for your Christmas dinner
let's start with my favorite vegetable
which is carrots I have carrots almost
every day what we have here is honey soy
glazed carrots the carrots are so sweet
and the flavor is nicely balanced out
with a little bit of soya sauce even if
your kids do not like vegetables they
will like this the ingredients you'll
need are 250 gram of carrots sliced 1
tablespoon of
one tablespoon of olive oil half a
tablespoon of soy sauce and black pepper
the first step is to bring one pot of
water to boil add the carrots and cook
until tender for seven to eight minutes
and drain in a pan heat one tablespoon
of olive oil over medium-high heat stir
in the carrots and soy sauce and cook
until the carrots are slightly browned
in spots for about three to four minutes
then stir in the honey and cook for
another two minutes until the carrots
are nicely glazed season with a little
bit of pepper sprinkle some droids of
fresh makes Hubbs and serve each serving
has 186 calories sir sauce is known to
promote healthy sleep and stabilize
boots to gain the health benefits from
your sir sauce it is important to check
that your sauce has been fermented in a
traditional manner there is no added
artificial color or flavor and no added
msg soy sauce is very high in sodium
in fact one tablespoon has about 1000
milligrams of sodium
therefore you should consume it in very
very small quantity
the next recipe is sweet apple red
cabbage so we are using two ingredients
that works really well together to make
a crunchy sweet salad the ingredients
you need are 300 grams of red cabbage
finely sliced that's about a quarter of
a large cabbage one medium-sized apple
chopped into small cubes one tablespoon
of apple cider vinegar 1 tablespoon of
mixed seeds one clove of garlic crushed
and 1 TSP of olive oil in a pan heat
olive oil over medium-high heat and cook
the crushed garlic until fragrant then
stir in the red cabbage and Apple for
five minutes or until cabbage starts to
wilt add the vinegar and continue to
stir and cook until the vinegar has
almost disappeared for another three to
four minutes transfer the vegetables
into a bowl sprinkle with mixed seeds
and serve this is for two servings one
large serving only has one hundred and
sixty one point five calories and it
will definitely keep you satisfied apple
cider vinegar has lots of health
benefits one of it is to suppress
appetite so stop adding a little bit of
apple cider vinegar into your cooking or
mix one teaspoon of apple cider vinegar
with warm water have it prayer to your
meal or even in the morning so try this
large bowl of crunchy sweet salad it's
so quick and easy to make you can pack
it up and have it for lunch at work or
have it as a snack to boost your energy
and finally a must-have vegetable for
your Christmas meal this saute Brussels
sprouts with sultanas will complete your
vegetable menu to make this classic dish
the ingredients you need are 250 grams
of Brussels sprouts trimmed and half
half of a ring
finely sliced quarter cup of chicken
stock or vegetable stock one teaspoon of
olive oil 30 gram of salt on--is two
cloves of garlic finely sliced and salt
and pepper to taste in a pan heat olive
oil over medium-high heat stir in the
red onion and Brussels sprouts and saute
for four minutes then add garlic and
saute for another four to five minutes
until the garlic is slightly Brown don't
forget to stir frequently then add the
chicken stock and allow all the
ingredients to cook for another two
minutes until the broth has almost
evaporated and the sprouts are crisp
tender don't forget to stir occasionally
remove from the heat season with a
little bit of salt and pepper and top
the dish up with some chela's
and serve to keep your Brussels sprouts
crunchy and sweet the key is not to
overcook it this one serving only has
one hundred and thirty seven point five
calories and this will complete your
Christmas dinner so for this Christmas
we want to add lots of vegetables into
your meal and the vegetables should also
be the highlight of your dinner try this
recipe out for Christmas dinner New
Year's party or even throughout the year
vegetables should make the largest
portion in your meals as you start
adding more vegetables into your daily
intake you will see and feel the
difference it is great to help you to
maintain your weight and to lose weight
so let me know which is your favorite in
the comments below for new Fitness food
and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my You Tube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
[Music]
you